review scores are in for alen Wing 2 and
they are very good which I'm so glad
about because I am so excited about this
game IGN gave it a N9 out of 10 saying
Allen weight 2 is a superb survival
horror sequel that makes the c classic
original seem like little more than a
rough first draft by comparison which
honestly it is so nuts when you look at
gameplay of alen wake next to Allan Wake
2 like they've come so far I feel like
this game is like remedy taking
everything they've learned from every
game they've made and just heightening
all of it Gamespot gave it a complete 10
out of 10 they noted the campaigns that
feel symbiotic and equally vital yet
diverse they mentioned a really cool use
of multimedia and how meta the game is
they said it's visually striking and
delivers on the ambition but they did
Note One negative which is specifically
a couple of bugs with one particular
thing the caseboard mechanics Screen
Rant Games Radar VGC vg247 or give it a
five out of five in fact the only mixed
review that's currently on Metacritic is
from Metro Game Central and says A
peculiar sequel that at times seems to
be purposly undermining the best
elements of the original but it still
gets just enough right to please both
existing fans and potential newcomers